>>Nichole: Literacy has always been
defined by the technology, right?
Before the printing press,
your ability to orally recite
something meant to be literate.
And so as technology has made things
cheaper, we're now saying, "Well hmm,
is someone literate if they cannot
critique media, take media in,
if they're only taking
in traditional text?"
So if a sixth grader today, by the
time they graduate from college,
is not fluent, if you will, in
some of these other forms of media,
I would venture to say that they
won't necessarily be considered
as being literate.
The Digital Youth Network was
started over five years ago,
really out of trying to understand
how we can support youth in learning
to use digital media,
initially for schoolwork.
But the more we thought about it,
and the more we realized how the
world was changing and evolving,
we realized we really needed
to help them understand how
to use digital media for
all aspects of their life.
Our population of youth were urban
youth, living in the city of Chicago.
And we couldn't assume that they were
gonna learn how to use technologies
and media in the way that we
wanted in their home life.
So we had to figure out how to
make it happen within the context
of school or in the space
where kids connect into school.
And we realized that so many
efforts around tech integration
in school have failed, mainly
because the purpose was to try
to get teachers to be the ones who
taught kids how to use technology.
And we just knew that that
couldn't be the way to go.
First, because our kids were
more digitally sophisticated
than teachers.
We've also then, in the last
year, established a partnership
with the Chicago Public
Library to open
up a high school only space called
YOUmedia, which is a space just
for ninth through twelfth graders.
And in that partnership, the Chicago
Public Library provides the space,
provides the library, and we
provide the digital mentors,
who collaborate collectively with the
librarians to create opportunities,
learning opportunities,
digital opportunities for youth.
We've also created a social
network called Remix Learning,
and that's a platform
that youth use to connect
to one another twenty-four seven.
So the DYN is an after-school
program, an in school program,
a shared space with YOUmedia, and
is also an online social space.
What we initially did is, we asked
teachers to just come and watch
and to look at their students and to
see their students using technology
in a way that was very different from
how they were using it in a school.
So they saw their students and
producers and creators of technology.
They saw them creating videos.
They saw them creating some
video games, music and songs,
and what they saw, which
many of them talked about,
is that they saw students who were
quiet in the school day come alive
in the after-school space.
>>Student: The thing that drawed me in about
DYN was the studio that was upstairs,
and that's just like a place
that I'd love to be in.
It's a spot for inspiration really,
and on top of the inspiration,
it's the spot where you have
the tools as well, to again,
like I said earlier, bring
out what you want to,
what you hear in your head, and
putting it in front of a camera
or in a beat machine, or on paper.
And if you know how to
use it, this is amazing.
>>Nichole: I think we've structured our
work with students in such a way to try
to create a cycle where they
are developing the skill sets,
but they're constantly making use
of those skills, in ways that are,
you know, first personally
beneficial,
but also beneficial to their society.
We have a trajectory, if
we will, and it's first,
you're just a regular DYN kid
and you're learning how
to use digital media.
And if you choose to like
really develop a passion,
to geek out if you will, in one area,
then you can become a junior mentor.
Because now you've
developed a set of skills
that we think can be
used to teach others.
And at that point, there's a set of
responsibilities that come with that.
One is, you're responsible for
working with those who are younger,
and teaching them how to
do what it is that you do.
But then, you also get more
specialized support in mentoring
to help take your skill
sets to a different level.
You get opportunities
to be professional
and to go record your work.
And if you really do this
for a couple of years,
and you demonstrate some mastery,
if you will, you can get paid
to do this particular work.
>>Student: I started off as just the
student, but now I'm getting paid
to do what they do, and that's
how long I've been with it.
And now, I actually
have my own class,
and I used to just be
a part of the class.
And I don't know any teenager
or senior in high school
that has a class full of
students where they get to teach
and create their own curriculum.
>>Nichole: I think the ways in which
most technologies have been brought
into the classroom
in videos and things,
they've come in with
a natural audience.
So I think if you were just doing
the video that only your teacher saw,
I think eventually you
would get to the point
that that would be the
same as doing an essay.
But I think because
oftentimes they're brought in,
what you're gonna share with
your classmates, you can take in
and share it with your
parents or with your friends,
that that motivates you to do work.
>>Student: But before his voice box
was completely boxed in,
he thought to himself, "Why
should I silence myself?"
>>Nichole: Part of what we've also
been trying to understand is,
"Well, does this matter?"
What impact does it have
besides, "Yes, it's good,
a kid can make a video or a podcast?"
Does it lead to a set of
portfolio, a set of skill sets
that can impact their life?
So we did a three year
ethnography on a group of kids,
starting from the sixth grade,
in their sixth grade year,
following them all the way through
the end of their eighth grade year.
And the question really
was, "Okay, so what?
Does this matter?"
And we needed to compare
them to a group of kids
who we felt were probably
exemplifying what digital natives
should be.
And so we chose to compare our kids
to a group of kids in Silicon Valley,
kids who grew up in environments
where it was just sorta in the water,
the use of digital media.
Their parents work for tech firms.
And we wanted to see, could we
create an ecology, if you will,
a cocoon of in school, after
school, online social capital here
in Chicago, where our kids could
begin to look like those kids
in terms of the digital,
their digital portfolios.
And so starting at the beginning
of the sixth grade year,
as one would suspect,
ninety-six percent
of our kids had fewer digital media
experiences, portfolios if you will,
than the kids in Silicon Valley.
And every year we tested
it and, you know,
we looked at where we were going.
At the end of the sixth grade year,
beginning of seventh grade year,
I think seventy-six percent of
our kids had more experiences
than the kids in Silicon Valley.
And at the end of the eighth grade
year, I believe the number is more
like eighty-six or
eighty-four percent
of our kids had more,
have more experiences.
Almost any kid that you
look at and you say, "Oh wow,
this is a great user of digital
media," you can trace back.
There's a parent, there's, you
know, a program, there's something
that inspired them
and developed them.
And that we need to make sure that
we have those types of programs
and those people represented
equally throughout all of society.